[Musik]
die psychiatrische Klinik Belle liegt
dort wo man die psychischer Kranken
lange haben wollte am Ende der Welt
[Musik]
ich habe meine Jugend im Kanton Jura
verbracht sobald wir uns etwas außerhalb
der Norm benahmen hieß es du änderst
noch bei den Irren in Bälle
[Musik]
ursprünglich war belehrt im Berner Jura
ein Kloster nachdem die Abtei
geschlossen wurde fanden die Menschen
hier medizinische Hilfe seit 130 Jahren
ist Belle eine psychiatrische Klinik es
gibt den Geist von Bälle heute ist es
für viele Patienten ein guter Geist
[Musik]
es ist das zweite daheim wenn es nicht
mehr geht würde ich sagen
[Musik]
damit ist nun Schluss die umzugsautos
stehen bereit
gegen den Willen der Mehrheit der
Patientinnen und Patienten und des
Personals wird die psychiatrische Klinik
in Spital von Mutti integriert zu
abgelegen und kaum wirtschaftlich zu
betreiben sei Bälle sagen die Behörden
[Musik]
morgen sobald man den Dienst beginnt
spürt man schon ob die Stimmung ruhig
oder angespannt ist werden Türen
zugeschlagen schreien Patientinnen oder
schlafen noch alle und es ist ruhig
weil jemand aggressiv ist
[Musik]
unsere Schritte im Gang all diese
Geräusche bedeuten Alltag
einen Klinikalltag wie in Bälle wird es
so wohl bald nicht mehr geben
der Kostendruck ist zu hoch geworden
[Musik]
an meinem ersten Arbeitstag als ich
meinen Ausbildner hier traf brach ich in
Tränen aus ich sagte ich kann das nicht
ich kann nicht hier bleiben ich habe
Angst
[Musik]
heute weiß ich dass es Einbildung war
aber damals habe ich es sehr stark
empfunden ich werde vielleicht
geschlagen oder angegriffen dachte ich
ich wollte nicht hier sein
Celine Bär Fuß arbeitet seit zehn Jahren
hier und ist stellvertretende
pflegechefin in Bälle
hier geht es oft runter und drüber das
liebe ich an meiner Arbeit ich habe es
gern wenn etwas läuft und der Tag ist
schlecht wenn Dinge verschleppt werden
oder ich im Büro rumsitzen muss ich bin
ein Bewegungsmensch und gerne bei den
Patienten so bin ich sonst ist es mir
langweilig
hier in die Abteilung 1 kommen
Patientinnen die sich in einer akuten
Krise befinden
[Musik]
diese junge Frau leidet unter einer
psychischen Dekompensation
umgangssprachlich Nervenzusammenbruch
Celine und ihr Team versuchen sie zu
beruhigen
[Musik]
wenn eine Person ankommt die ruhig ist
gehe ich allein zu ihr und stelle mich
vor ich spreche mit ruhiger Stimme und
versuche keine abrupten Bewegungen zu
machen
[Musik]
Patient in Aufruhr ist und Angst hat
dann ist es viel schwieriger weil wir
dann mehrere pflegende sind das beruhigt
vielleicht uns aber nicht unbedingt den
Patienten
wir versuchen ruhig zu sprechen aber
manchmal funktioniert es trotzdem nicht
[Musik]
wir sind ein Notfalldienst eine
Krisenintervention man braucht schon
etwas Lebenserfahrung und Bodenhaftung
um die Situation hier aufzufangen
es gibt viel Leid und auch viel Gewalt
viele schwierige Momente
es ist ein Ort an dem sich die Situation
extrem schnell ändern kann es kann ruhig
sein und eine Viertelstunde später
fliegt einem alles um die Ohren
es ist fast wie ein pulverfassbar
bin
der Chef Pfleger der Abteilung ist
erfahren und schon lange her seine
Motivation hat über die Jahre nicht
abgenommen
ist ein großer Teil meines Lebens seit
1993 gehe ich in diesem Haus ein und aus
für das Leiden der Menschen Lösungen zu
finden Hilfe zu organisieren das ist
meine berufliche Passion
hier müssen wir eine Lösung finden es
ist ein schwieriger Entzug wir sind nun
auf 4 x 50 mg Silvester gegangen sie hat
fast nicht geschlafen nur etwa 3 Stunden
bezüglich diesem isolationszimmer ich
würde sagen wir lockern von Zeit zu Zeit
aber wir vereinbaren einen klaren Rahmen
mit ihm und wenn er uns die WC-Schüssel
kaputt macht macht er sie halt kaputt
ich habe Angst dass wir sonst Anti
therapeutisch werden wenn es nicht geht
streichen wir die Lockerungen wieder
Marco
behandelt werden hier unter anderem
bipolare Störungen Schizophrenie schwere
Depressionen Burnouts
neben der Notfallabteilung gibt es eine
Abteilung welche auf ältere Personen mit
psychischen Problemen spezialisiert ist
und eine welche sich um Personen mit
psychischen Erkrankungen kümmert deren
Zustand stabil ist
[Musik]
wie oft bist du schon hierher gekommen
etwas zehnmal glaube ich
nach einer Weile funktionieren meine
Medikamente jeweils nicht mehr richtig
und dann bin ich wieder hier
Leona ist 26 und hat eine lange
Geschichte mit der Klinik Welle
ist für mich manchmal ein Spital
manchmal ein Ort um zur Ruhe zu kommen
je nachdem in welcher Abteilung ich
platziert werde
mich schon
ich bin völlig zusammengebrochen es war
hart ich musste auch in Isolation ich
habe alle Stufen der Psychiatrie
durchgemacht
die Einsamkeit des isolationszimmers
wobei die Pflegenden diese Bezeichnung
nicht mögen
sind schon seit aussieht dieses Zimmer
ist ein Raum für die Intensivpflege
hierher verlegen wir Patienten die für
sich selbst oder für andere eine Gefahr
darstellen es wird sehr genau abgewogen
ob jemand den isolationszimmer kommt man
weiß ja dass man jemandem die Freiheit
nimmt und dass die Türe von außen
geschlossen wird
es ist nie einfach dort eingeschlossen
zu sein in diesem Zimmer gibt es einfach
nichts
[Musik]
die Patienten drücken ihre Gefühle oft
aus indem Sie auf die Mauern schreiben
sie sind ja wirklich allein
[Musik]
man bringt mir dort einzig das Essen und
einen Löffel ich habe keine Brille keine
Hausschuhe keine Uhr
in der Isolation ist man wenn es
wirklich nicht mehr geht
in solchen Momenten ist man von der
realen Welt sowieso völlig abgeschnitten
[Musik]
man dreht sich im Kreis man weiß nie wie
viel Uhr es ist es ist ziemlich mühsam
auf der anderen Seite gibt es einem die
Zeit über sich selbst nachzudenken
über alles was nicht gut läuft
als Bastian 29 Jahre alt war wurde er
das erste Mal hier hospitalisiert doch
er kannte Belle schon zuvor
Akademie in meiner beruflichen Laufbahn
in der so ziemlich alles schief lief
wollte ich auch einmal Pfleger werden
ich habe hier mein Praktikum gemacht das
aber nicht gut verlaufen ist
ich hatte also keine Lust nach Bälle
zurückzukommen
[Musik]
ich bin
depressivheit
den ganzen Tag lang an etwas herum an
isoliert sich hat dunkle Gedanken
suizidale Gedanken
[Musik]
und im schlimmsten Fall schreitet man
zur Tat ich bin freiwillig hergekommen
ich weiß wieso ich hier bin
aus der Krise zu finden ich brauche
Bälle
es gibt einige die unfreiwillig hier
sind für sie ist es schwieriger
sie verstehen nicht wieso sie hier sind
und wollen weg
einige kommen aus freiem Willen aber
viele sind hier in einer sogenannt
fürsorgerischen Unterbringung und wurden
gegen ihren Willen eingewiesen viele
wollen weg wie dieser junge Mann der
regelmäßigen Bälle ist er riss aus und
landete in einer psychiatrischen
Einrichtung in Frankreich deshalb die
weißen Kleider siehst du gut gereist
haben sie dir was gespritzt ja sie haben
mir Neuroleptika gespritzt das hat mich
stabilisiert
ich hoffe nur dass sie mich nicht
einsperrt das wäre cool
sind deine Taschen leer
die Pflegenden begleiten und durchsuchen
den jungen Mann machen eine Urinprobe
die Abläufe sind klar festgelegt
auch zuhören ist wichtig denn die
Patienten sind durch ihre Krankheit oft
geschwächt und ängstlich
ich habe keinen einzigen Joint geraucht
nur in einem Maß danach nicht mehr
ich habe schon Leute ankommen sehen die
sehr sehr große Angst hatten wir
schließen zwar die Türen ab und nehmen
Patienten die Freiheit
ich bin wieder auf dem Boden der
Realität gelandet
[Musik]
nicht abzuschließen um jemanden zu
strafen oder zu vergessen
nein hinter den verschlossenen Türen ist
die Pflege sehr intensiv folgt klaren
Abläufen
[Musik]
doch viele Menschen verbinden die Pflege
in der Psychiatrie mit Zwangsmaßnahmen
[Musik]
die Leute haben eine falsche Vorstellung
davon was wir machen sie denken ans
einsperren an spritzen sie denken wir
sind irgendwie Wachen oder irrenaufseher
[Musik]
ich finde es schade dass man dieses Bild
der Psychiatrie hat unser Beruf besteht
nicht darin die Leute einzuschließen
unsere Arbeit ist nicht fertig wenn wir
jemanden aufgenommen haben dem es nicht
gut geht wir begleiten die Personen
versuchen zu verstehen eine Beziehung
aufzubauen zu erklären und die Einsicht
in eine Krankheit oder eine nötige
Behandlung zu fördern
ich möchte gerne Medikamente gegen
Durchfall wegen des Lithiums
haben sie die Ärzte informiert oder
sollen wir das machen
sie wissen es
[Musik]
ungerecht und hartherzig das Image der
Psychiatrie kommt nicht von ungefähr
[Musik]
bis Ende der 70er Jahre waren die
Methoden in Bälle ganz anders als heute
Roland kam 1971 als Pfleger in die
Klinik
er erinnert sich
histie Psychiatrie war von der
Gesellschaft völlig abgeschottet es gab
keine Durchmischung es gab zwar eine
Pflege sie war auch nicht so schlecht
aber man hatte klare Vorstellungen über
psychische Erkrankungen das war etwas
was man abschirmen und wegschließen
musste
es war noch die Psychiatrie des 20
Jahrhundert die seine Jünger es hatte
etwas gefängnishaftes wechselte
[Musik]
das Einsperren führte zu Unruhe und zu
einer inneren Isolation
Forum die soll mal er hat auch bei den
Pflegenden
[Musik]
in den 80er Jahren kam Bewegung in die
Psychiatrie auch in Bälle
vieles änderte sich unter dem Einfluss
des fortschrittlichen Psychiaters dr
wann
die Gesellschaft hat in ihrer
Grausamkeit nur eine Lösung gefunden für
die psychisch Kranken sie wegzusperren
damit beruhigte man sich selbst im Sinne
von wir sind gesund und wir sind
verrückt
20 Jahre lang anders gemacht wir haben
die Türen der Klinik geöffnet und ich
glaube nicht dass es dem Berner Jura
deswegen schlechter geht
es gab diese schnelle sehr schnelle
Öffnung wirklich man hat die Abteilungen
geöffnet es gab eine ganz neue Sicht auf
psychische Erkrankungen
sind Klinik diese Klinik wurde bekannt
dafür
haben wir zum Beispiel einen Tag der
offenen Tür eingeführt die Leute kamen
und waren erstaunt als sie sahen wie es
hier läuft hier läuft menschliches
nichts anderes
trotz dieser Öffnung blieb der Name
Belvedere für viele mit den alten
Bildern der Psychiatrie verknüpft
[Musik]
immer noch etwas von einer Anstalt an
auch wenn sich viel geändert hat in den
Köpfen der Menschen das Bild der Anstalt
bleibt
darum bleibt es für viele schwierig
hierherzukommen
bella ist mit negativen Bildern aus der
Vergangenheit konnotiert
das sieht man bei gewissen Familien
[Musik]
aus der Familie eine Tochter ein Sohn
nach Bälle kommen muss
[Musik]
wer noch als die Mitarbeitenden sind es
die Patientinnen und Patienten die unter
den alten Geschichten aus der
Psychiatrie leiden
viele der Patienten die ich hier kenne
wurden stigmatisiert weil sie krank sind
ich finde das abscheulich
das doch nicht aus
natürlich aber unsere Krankheiten
scheinen anderen Angst zu machen doch
wir sind keine Monster wir können normal
vor eine Kamera treten wir sind nicht
ansteckend
wenn ich von deiner Krankheit gewusst
hätte hätte ich dich nicht mit den
Kindern spielen lassen
das
schmerzt wirklich
aber es zeigt vor allem wie wenig die
Menschen über psychische Krankheiten
Wissen und die wenigste überlegen was
solche Bemerkungen auslösen können
[Musik]
wenn man mit den Menschen über
psychische Erkrankungen spricht also
über Depressionen oder gewisse andere
Diagnosen
so spürt man ihre Angst davor auch bei
sich selbst findet man diese Angst
es gibt eine unbewusste Identifikation
der Menschen damit im Sinne von auch
mich könnte es eines Tages treffen auch
mehr könnte es schlecht gehen ich könnte
die Kontrolle verlieren könnte
zusammenbrechen die Patientinnen der
Psychiatrie spiegeln diese Angst
er fühlt sich nicht bereit dazu nach
Hause zu gehen er will mit uns nach
Mutti kommen
mir scheint es geht ihm etwas besser
aber wir müssen noch schauen wie das
Anti psychotikum wirkt er will erst
etwas ändern wenn es ihm wieder super
gut geht wir müssen ihm aufzeigen dass
er einfach machen muss und es so besser
wird er wartet vor allem darauf dass
seine Freundin zurückkommt er sagt wenn
er heimgehen müsse wird er wieder
konsumieren
seine Freundin zurückkommt
wir müssen eine neue Freundin für ihn
finden
wir helfen den Patienten die Dinge aus
einer anderen Perspektive zu sehen das
macht diesen Beruf so schön dabei zu
helfen etwas zu verändern ein Wohnheim
zu finden je nachdem
sie ist gekommen um sich bei uns zu
bedanken
auch wenn es immer noch viele Vorurteile
gibt sind psychische Erkrankungen heute
kein endgültiges Urteil mehr
die Patientinnen und Patienten werden
therapeutisch begleitet wie hier in der
Abteilung 2 in dieser Abteilung kommt
wird die akute Krise überwunden hat
hier ist alles etwas lockerer die
Patienten werden begleitet man hört
ihnen zu
diese Psychiatrie mag ich die Therapie
die Gespräche die professionellen und
die informellen das mag ich sehr
[Musik]
auf dem Stock der Abteilung 2 liegt auch
das beschäftigungsatelier
[Musik]
für die Patienten und Patientinnen ein
Ort zum Durchatmen und um auf andere
Ideen zu kommen
[Musik]
hier könnten alle sich selbst sein es
werde nicht geurteilt und es würden
keine Diagnosen gestellt das sagen uns
die Patientinnen oft sie können sich
hier gehen lassen
sich hier nicht wie in einem Spital es
sei wie eine Insel
[Musik]
schon beim ersten Aufenthalt habe ich
sofort gesagt dass ich ins Atelier will
sie waren einverstanden direkt ich habe
mich sofort wohl gefühlt nicht anders
hier kann ich in Frieden sein mit mir
selbst
[Musik]
ich hatte auch sofort ein gutes
Verhältnis zu den Mitarbeiterinnen
es tut gut mit ihnen zu lachen und zu
weinen
das geht nicht unbedingt mit einer
Pflegerin oder einem Arzt
[Musik]
pression das hier ist kein
Ferienaufenthalt auch wenn es vielleicht
so aussehen mag aber wir sind hier um
gesund zu werden es ist das Gegenteil
von Ferien alle haben irgendein Problem
und arbeiten daran
gesund zu werden ist nicht nur ein Job
es ist ein ganzes Unterfangen
das Leben als Patient oder Patientin ist
nicht einfach auch wenn man leidet gilt
es voran zu gehen und die
therapeutischen Ziele weiter zu
verfolgen
nach mehreren Wochen in der
Krisenintervention wurde Bastian in die
Abteilung 2 verlegt mit seiner
Sozialarbeiterin bereitet er seinen
Austritt vor wie geht es
gut gut
haben sie am Wochenende ihre Eltern
gesehen
dass sie am Donnerstag die neue Wohnung
besichtigen können
ihre Mutter sie abholen sie holt mich
und bringt mich wieder zurück
der Arzt weiß auch Bescheid er hat die
Absenz am Donnerstagnachmittag bewilligt
zu werden zu schwimmen Sport zu treiben
um mich wieder besser zu fühlen in
meinem Körper
wegen der Medikamente habe ich stark
zugenommen ich möchte mich wieder um
mich kümmern
Buch
animieren
vielleicht kann ich auch in einer
geschützten Werkstatt etwas arbeiten
[Musik]
damit ich beschäftigt bin
ziele zu haben ist hilfreich doch die
Klinik zu verlassen und nach Hause zu
gehen bleibt eine Herausforderung auch
für Vivian sie packt ihre Koffer nachdem
sie mehrere Wochen in der Klinik
verbracht hat
meine Mutter ist gestorben meine
Schwägerin ist gestorben es kam viel
zusammen auch familiäre Probleme
am Ende hatte ich eine Art Burnout
wieder nach Hause zu gehen ist hart man
schließt die Menschen hier ins Herz weil
alle ein Leiden haben jeder hat
irgendein Problem so ist es einfach
Kontakt zu finden
sogar wenn man jemanden erst zwei Tage
kennt versteht man sich gut wenn man das
gleiche erlebt hat
[Musik]
das Foto kommt zurück ins Portemonnaie
ich wollte es nahe bei mir haben
emotional es ist schwierig heimzugehen
allen Adieu zu sagen die Patientinnen
sind auch füreinander eine große Hilfe
nicht nur die Ärzte und die Pflegenden
unter den Patienten wird viel diskutiert
man tauscht sich aus manchmal weint
jemand dann spricht man über das Problem
man hilft sich gegenseitig
also danke für alles passen Sie auf sich
auf
[Musik]
vielleicht ja aber anderswo
alles Gute
von gibt es vielleicht Menschen die
denken beläser für die verrückten ein
Irrenhaus aber es ist kein Ort für
Verrückte die Menschen hier sind
sensible Menschen die Probleme haben
wunderbare wertvolle Menschen mit einem
großen Herz
man hat mir schon gesagt ich soll eine
irre weil ich depressiv bin und den
Balea war aber wir sind nicht verrückt
wir haben nur mehr Mühe unsere Gefühle
zu regulieren
natalie ist für einen Besuch
zurückgekommen
erst vor kurzem wurde sie nach einem
Monat Aufenthalt aus Bälle entlassen
es ist besser hierher zu kommen und
nicht Patientin zu sein
ja wir suchen ist besser
können wir etwas für dich tun
hättet ihr nicht dann Plätzchen für zwei
drei Tage
[Gelächter]
dein damaliges Zimmer ist nicht besetzt
ich bin draußen mit allen in Kontakt
geblieben
kann und auftanke
hier kann man alles vergessen alle
Probleme es gibt keine Stadt es gibt
einfach nichts außer Wiesen kommt
ich war eigentlich nicht bereit
umzugehen ich hatte das Gefühl nicht
genug Kraft zu haben
ich habe eine Sozialphobie und sobald es
zu viele Menschen hat geht es nicht mehr
aber ja ich schlage mich durch
[Musik]
ein Asyl ein geschützter Ort auf Zeit
das Wort Asyl bedeutet dass man an einem
sicheren Ort ist
hier bedeutet es auch dass man in diesem
geschützten Rahmen wieder lernt soziale
Kontakte aufzubauen
muss nach Hause zu gehen man hat mir
erzählt dass man sogar schon die Polizei
rufen musste um eine Person nach Hause
zu bringen alle brauchen soziale
Kontakte diese kann man hier gut
aufbauen trotzdem kommt der Moment an
dem man gehen muss
heute dauert ein Aufenthalt in
bel-durchschnittlich 3 Wochen
[Musik]
früher aber war die Klinik ein Ort fürs
Leben
genau das ist witzig man weiß gar nicht
wer Patientin und wer Pfleger ist sie
spielen wohl schach
ist
Psychiatrie Geschichte die Geschichte
wird weitergegeben an jede neue
Generation von pflegenden jeder von uns
ist ein kleines Stück dieser Geschichte
des großen Ganzen was für mich
heraussticht sind die starken Werte
Menschenwürde Sicherheit
Authentizität
es wurde hier ein Arbeitsort mit einer
Art mikro-gesellschaft geschaffen ein
Ort an dem sich die Patienten in
Sicherheit fühlen und ihr Leiden leben
können
[Musik]
diesen geschützten Rahmen wird auch
Bastian bald verlassen
also am 28 gehe ich ich habe darum
gebeten ich will vorwärts machen
wie ein totaler Feigling
es ist gut dass du gehst besser
Bastian
[Musik]
habe ich ein bisschen unter meine
Fittiche genommen
am Anfang war es sehr hart für ihn
es gab sehr schwierige Momente da konnte
ich auch nichts machen
aber ich habe den Pflegenden Bonbons
mitgegeben mit Botschaften an ihn um ihn
Mut zu machen
wenn er mich sah war er richtig
glücklich
es tut mir gut wenn ich Menschen Lächeln
sehe
[Musik]
die Nacht erinnert daran dass vieles in
belef fragile ist
für die Pflege asmeer und corenta ist es
die Zeit in der sie einige Patienten in
ihre Zimmer zurückbringen
Moment das Durchsuchen der Patienten und
der Zimmer eine informelle Befragung
geführt mit sanfter Stimme es wird alles
unternommen um ein Unglück zu verhindern
[Musik]
hattest du einen guten Tag nein warum
ich habe Angst vor meiner Familie
wenn du Angst hast
können wir dir Medikamente geben die ich
etwas beruhigen ist das in Ordnung
nun ist es Zeit ins Zimmer zu gehen er
nimmt es genau ja
schönen Abend
meistens kommen die Ängste am Abend
zurück oder werden stärker das ist wie
ein kleiner Tod oft sind es schwierige
Momente für die Patientinnen und
Patienten du bist alleine die
Gesellschaft der anderen ist weg dann
ist auf sich selbst zurückgeworfen auf
seine Gefühle seine Sorgen das Leiden
als Nachtwache erlebt man sehr
persönliche Momente sehr viel Nähe
in meinen Augen ist die Nacht eine sehr
gute Schule denn man ist gezwungen sich
auf alle seine Fähigkeiten und
Erfahrungen auf alle Zusammenhänge zu
besinnen in den inneren Konflikt zu
bewältigen die Nacht ist eine
hervorragende Schule
[Musik]
mit dem Tagesanbruch weichen die
Abgründe der Nacht Hoffnung und
Aufbruchstimmung nehmen Oberhand
[Musik]
beginnt den Tag mit neuem Mut
bitte
ich war am Boden des Abgrunds als ich
vor zweieinhalb Wochen hier ankam dann
musste ich den Hang wieder hinaufsteigen
und vor allem meine Lebensfreude
wiederfinden die ich vollkommen verloren
hatte
nun geht es besser
vor allem wegen etwas das man Liebe
nennt ich habe jemanden getroffen
niemals hätte ich daran gedacht dass ich
in Belle Liebe finden würde deswegen
kommt man ja nicht hierher
dann lieber auf den ersten Blick habe
ich sowieso nicht geglaubt
und auch nicht daran dass ich mich so
schnell wieder verlieben könnte
[Musik]
viele Ängste auslösen
aber die Klinik steht auch am Anfang
einiger schöner Geschichten
gut geschlafen
[Musik]
sie ist auf der Abteilung 2
untergebracht
[Musik]
es ließ sich kein Heim für Sie finden
so ist Belle ihr daheim geworden ein
Beispiel für die menschliche Haltung
dieser Klinik
sie ist rührend ich glaube es gibt
niemanden hier deren Namen nicht kennt
und ich glaube es gibt niemanden der sie
nicht liebt
sie hat dieses Talent geliebt zu werden
wenn sie kommt und meine Hand nimmt und
mich bitte Zeit mit dir zu verbringen
sie braucht eine sehr spezifische und
intensive Betreuung
zu finden der diese Bedürfnisse abdeckt
als Lebensort doch eigentlich sollte es
einen solchen Ort auch außerhalb geben
ich höre zu
[Musik]
Königin deines Körpers aber wenn es
blutet was machst du dann genau wir
sehen uns morgen
[Musik]
bis morgen süße
arbeitet seit 20 Jahren in Belle
sie hat fast mütterliche Gefühle für die
Patientinnen und Patienten
sie kommen und sagen oh Mama wie geht es
Dir
ich verbringe manchmal etwas Zeit mit
ihnen lache Spiele
es gab welche die fragten mich ob sie
mir ein Küsschen geben dürfen ich habe
gesagt ja klar das hat sie gefreut und
mich hat es gefreut dass es sie gefreut
hat
ich habe das Gefühl dass sie etwas
Zuneigung brauchen dass sie davon zu
wenig haben und diese Dinge sind ja
gerade ist
ich habe in einer Fabrik gearbeitet und
in der Gastronomie aber hier habe ich
meinen Platz gefunden
hier habe ich viel gelernt für mein
Leben meine ich
aber früher musste ich mir immer in
Tritt in den Hintern geben um zur Arbeit
zu gehen wenn es nun Probleme gibt
Urteile ich nicht mehr auch nicht
draußen
[Musik]
nicht urteilen einfach nur
Menschlichkeit zeigen dieser Mission
wird die Belegschaft bald anders vor
umsetzen
für den Umzug nach motier spreche die
zentralere Lage und die
endstigmatisierung psychischer
Krankheiten sagen die Befürworter
la premiere
als ich das erste Mal nach belekam hat
mich dieser Ort wirklich berührt
gleichzeitig habe ich mich gefragt ob es
richtig ist hier Leute zu pflegen
es ist ein wunderschöner Ort aber ich
habe den Eindruck dass es kein adäquater
Platz ist um Leute zu pflegen
das ist ein wunderschöner Ort voller
Geschichte geben von Wiesen und Wäldern
der Bus fährt zwei bis dreimal pro Tag
hin und zurück
aber ist es nicht besser mit den
Patientinnen und Patienten in der
Realität zu arbeiten
im echten Leben
indem wir nach mutier gehen zeigen wir
doch auch dass die psychische Gesundheit
nicht nur ein paar wenige etwas angeht
sie muss uns alle interessieren
aber auch finanzielle Überlegungen die
Klinik machte jahrelang Defizite das
wollte der Kanton nicht mehr tragen doch
die meisten hier sind gegen den Umzug
die Umgebung hier ist unser Werkzeug die
Gärtner die Natur
wenn man mit jemandem etwas besprechen
will und ein Sitzungszimmer zu formell
scheint geht man nach draußen das
kreiert eine andere Art von Beziehung
gerade mit Patientinnen in akuten Krisen
für Celine oft draußen Gespräche
mit dem unkontrollierten Essen an sich
damit konnte ich leben es war mehr das
danach wenn ich mir eingestehen musste
dass das einfach nicht normal ist dann
bedeutet das wohl dass es Gründe gibt
weshalb du hier bist
eine eigene Welt in der Welt
man ist etwas isoliert das erlaubt den
Menschen sich zurückzuziehen von all den
externen Stimuli welche oft mit ein
Grund sind für einen
zusammenbruche von anderen Leuten man
kann einfach man selbst sein
diese Landschaft der Ort gibt einem Ruhe
dieses Gebäude die Korridore die
Großzügigkeit der Räume
man kann sich hier bewegen ist nicht
eingeengt das ist natürlich ein
großartiges Arbeitsinstrument oder war
es leider
schon morgen ist hier Schluss Patrick
und Selen versuchen in Gesprächen die
Stimmung zu erfassen
Jona hängt sehr an diesem Ort
[Musik]
wie geht es ihnen sind sie gestresst
oder ängstlich oder freuen sie sich wir
erleben sie das alles
[Musik]
nach Mutti zu ziehen beunruhigt mich
schon
[Musik]
helfen könnte oder gibt es nichts das
hilft das ist ja auch möglich
stabil und nun bringt man sie zusätzlich
in eine Situation welche auch völlig
instabil ist mit Teams die überall
herumrennen Orte welche sie nicht kennen
viele sind mit Bälle sehr verbunden weil
sie mehrmals hierher kamen die Situation
ist für sie sehr beängstigend sie wird
es in Mut hier sein wird es gut sein
oder nicht wir versuchen die Menschen zu
stabilisieren dieser Umzug bringt alles
mit sich was in der Psychiatrie nicht
sein dürfte eine instabile Situation die
destabilisiert
[Musik]
ich habe mir eine kleine Strategie
überlegt für dich
dir den Kittel einer Pflegerin die magst
du doch so gerne und dann machen wir
einen Rollentausch und du wirst
Pflegerin
ich hoffe dass ich nächstes Jahr meine
Aufnahmeprüfungen für die Universität
machen kann
ich möchte einen Bachelor ein
Psychiatrie machen und dann eine
Ausbildung als Tiertherapeutin
oder in einer psychiatrischen
Einrichtung als peer-therapeutin
arbeiten
das wird lange dauern und nicht einfach
sein aber ich glaube mit der Hilfe
meines Umfelds kann ich es schaffen
[Musik]
diese Mauern haben alles gehört und
alles gesehen dramatisch ist Szenen
lautes Lachen Umarmungen Aufmunterung ja
es ist hart dass wir nun die Kisten
packen müssen es ist wirklich nicht
einfach
aber zu wissen dass das ganze Team
mitkommt ist eine Erleichterung
wenn man hier 15-16 Jahre war oder bei
Patrick noch länger ist es anders als
wenn man gerade angefangen hat
wir müssen wohl Trauerarbeit leisten es
ist eine Trauer
[Musik]
letzte Mahlzeit im Bälle letztes
Eintauchen in Erinnerungen in einigen
Stunden werden alle in mutier sein
[Musik]
super und ich schäme mich nicht in Belle
gewesen zu sein
ich schäme mich nicht zu sagen dass ich
krank bin ich fand es wichtig in diesem
Film zu sprechen über Belle und das
Umfeld hier
damit die Leute verstehen dass dies kein
furchtbarer kalter Ort war an dem die
Leute noch verrückter werden
das weiß auch der zuständige Direktor
der privaten spitalgruppe welche die
Klinik schon vor einiger Zeit vom Kanton
Bern übernommen hatte
natürlich habe auch ich gemischte
Gefühle
man hängt an zu einem Ort
dessen Geschichte in all ihren
Schattierungen hat Gewicht doch all das
was hier geleistet wurde wie Psychiatrie
vorangebracht wurde natürlich verbindet
man viel mit Billy ich denke aber dass
unser Weggang auch etwas erleichterndes
haben kann die Leute können nun einfach
sagen ich gehe ins Spital für einige
Zeit
man muss die Vergangenheit nicht
auslöschen aber der Psychiatrie ein
modernes Gesicht gibt
seltsames Gefühl nicht ja sehr seltsam
[Musik]
seit 14 Jahren komme ich jeden Morgen
hierher immer bin ich durch diese Allee
gegangen jeder Baum ist in meiner
Gedächtnis gespeichert
ja ja aber es gab hier auch wirklich
viel Leid
[Musik]